The speaking clock is an idea that goes all
the way back to 1933, when citizens of Paris
were the recipients of the first such service.
Since then, dozens of countries have implemented
a similar system that the public can call
to find out the exact time.
In the UK, the service has a long and storied
history and even today in the age of near
ubiquitous smartphones and the internet it’s
still called an astounding thirty million
times per year.
Prior to the introduction of the UK speaking
clock service in 1936, it’s noted that people
wanting to know the time who didn’t have
a clock or watch handy would simply call the
exchange operator and ask, resulting in operators
spending much of their time doing this, instead
of routing calls.
Prior to this, the somewhat official role
of a person telling people the time often
fell to employees of the Post Office, who
would pass it on to their mail coaches who
in turn would pass it on to the public when
asked as they made their rounds.
(For more ways people used to get the time,
see: Telling Time Before Ubiquitous Clocks.)
With exchange operators being inundated with
calls from people just wanting to know the
time, it was evident from almost the moment
telephones were first introduced and made
available to the British public in the last
years of the 19th century that an automated
speaking clock system was needed.
Unfortunately, the technology to record human
voices wasn’t widely commercially available
until around the mid-1920s.
Even then, it would take until the mid-1930s
for the Post Office, who controlled the telephone
system in the UK at the time, to begin designing
a machine that would accurately tell you the
time audibly.
The speaking clock machine eventually constructed
by the Post Office was relatively large and
contained “state of the art” technology
including using several electric motors, glass
discs, various valves, and photocells.
This system was evidently good enough that
the service wasn’t upgraded until 1963,
nearly three decades after it was originally
introduced.
With the system designed, a voice was needed.
As such the Post Office held a competition
to “the girl with the golden voice”.
No men were considered for the role as the
telephone orientated jobs were still seen
as a strictly female gendered profession back
then.
The winner of the contest would not only become
the voice of the speaking clock, but also
be given a prize of 10 guineas or about £700
today, a somewhat paltry sum given the billions
(after adjusting for inflation) the service
has earned in the ensuing decades since its
genesis.
The woman chosen for the gig was one Ethel
Jane Cain, a telephonist.
After being selected, Cain was given a script
of things to say.
She described the recording process in a 1957
Manchester Radio interview:
The way I recorded it was in jerks as it were.
I said: “At the Third Stroke” (that does
for all the times), and then I counted from
One, Two, Three, Four, for the hours, we even
went as far as twenty-four, in case the twenty-four-hour
clock should need to be used, and then I said
“…and ten seconds, and twenty seconds,
and thirty, forty, fifty seconds”, and “o’clock”
and “precisely”.
The famous “precisely”.
So what you hear is “At the Third Stroke
it will be one, twenty-one and forty seconds”
She went on to note that “the real work
was done by the engineers of the Post Office”
who had to painstakingly fit all her lines
together so they maintained a natural sounding
cadence.
For those who’ve never called before, since
1936, the line spoken by the talking clock
prior to announcing the time has remained
more or less exactly as Ethel described it-
the disembodied voice on the other end of
the line simply states, with little variation:
“At the third stroke, the time will be [insert
time here]” At which point three beeps will
play, the third of which will coincide with
the exact time mentioned followed by a brief
pause before the message plays again.
To call the service, users simply had to call
846, which spelled out the first three letters
of the word “time”, leading to the service
colloquially being known as “Tim” in the
areas of the country using this number (other
areas used other numbers until 1990 when the
number you needed to dial was changed more
simply to 123).
To
maintain the service, people calling were
initially charged a single penny, a figure
that has steadily risen over the years to
30p today, making the service incredibly profitable.
Officially introduced on July 24, 1936, the
British speaking clock service received approximately
13 million calls during its first year of
operation, a figure that becomes doubly impressive
when you realise the service was only available
in London for the first six years it existed.
With the massive number of calls coming in
at all hours, to make sure people didn’t
clog up the lines at any given time, the Post
Office issued a briefing after the system
was debuted, noting:
In view of the possibility of certain members
of the public becoming so enamoured of the
golden voice that they are impelled to listen
to it for an indefinite period, an automatic
device disconnects the circuit at the end
of ninety seconds.
While the idea of people becoming “enamoured”
with a recording of someone reading the time
might seem silly, Brian Cobby, the third “golden
voice” of the speaking clock claimed that
he often received fan-mail, particularly from
“older women”, who liked to call the speaking
clock at night when they couldn’t sleep,
just to listen to his soothing voice.
Speaking of Cobby, since its initial inception,
there have been four “permanent” (non-guest)
voices for the speaking clock, the aforementioned
Ethel Jane (you can hear her time reading
here), who provided the voice between 1936
and 1963; Pat Simmons (listen here), who provided
it from 1963 to 1984; actor Brian Cobby (listen
here), who lent his voice to the service from
1984 to 2007; and Sara Mendes da Costa (listen
here, or if you live in the UK just call the
number) who is the current voice of the service.
All four of these individuals became the voice
after entering a “golden voice” competition
similar to the one previously discussed and
were variously rewarded with cash prizes in
addition to becoming the new voice of the
service.
As for the accuracy of the speaking clock,
though many maintain that the modern speaking
clock is “accurate to within one five thousandth
of a second”, this claim is disputed by
the National Physics Laboratory who say that,
owing to variable delays in the transmission
actually getting to your phone: “you can
probably expect the starts of the seconds
pips to be accurate seconds markers within
about one-tenth of a second.”
This said, the service does take an extraordinary
amount of care in ensuring that the time they
give is as accurate as possible, even attempting
to account for the delay for the signal to
reach your phone.
The service is so accurate that a minor scandal
was caused in 2013 when it emerged that employees
at the Ministry of Defence had spent £40,000
of public money (about 130,000 calls) calling
the service to synchronize their clocks over
the previous three years, despite the fact
that doing exactly that was explicitly banned
by the Ministry of Defence in 2010.
Other than MOD employee calling to synchronise
watches, it has been noted that the service
fields the most calls on four very specific
days: The day the clocks go forward and back
for daylight saving time, New Year’s Eve
(with people trying to ensure they celebrate
the new year at the exact right moment) and
November the 11th (so that they can observe
the traditional 2 minutes silence for Remembrance
Day at the exact right time, 11AM).
Despite the huge technological leaps made
in the last few decades that would seem to
make such a service obsolete, the speaking
clock service still fields an estimated 30
million calls every year or about 82,000 calls
per day.
That said, this is markedly less than a little
under a decade ago before the ubiquity of
smart phones, when the service was pulling
in an average of about 200,000 calls per day.
With either numbers, at 30p a call, the speaking
clock is still raking
in
the money.